a shocking development to bring you
tonight in the immigration debate the
Department of Homeland Security says
that at least 142 suspected gang members
were put on our streets last year
because of sanctuary cities catch and
release policies unbelievable
now that flies in the face of what
Democrats have repeatedly insisted is
their real true intent let me be clear
anybody who in this country who see
who's who is undocumented who has
committed serious crimes they need to be
the poorest and I am NOT defending any
criminals I think that would be logic
for us and it doesn't make absolutely
any sense I believe that there needs to
be serious severe and swift consequence
when people commit serious and violent
crimes and certainly if they're
undocumented they should be deported if
they commit those serious and violent
offenses now let's get the real story
national Border Patrol council president
Brandon Judd joins us from Skype in
Montana and his group spokesman Border
Patrol agent Hector Garza is in San
Antonio gentlemen
I knew it was bad I didn't know it was
this bad
but now we have the numbers and the
numbers do not lie Brandon let's start
with you are you are you thinking at
this point the Democrats are gonna start
eating crow after all these comments
that oh we're not in favor of that
that's not what sanctuary city policies
actually do that's not what they
accomplish every night I hear something
like that on this show no Laura they're
they're not they're never going to admit
wrongdoing what they're gonna do is
they're gonna spin it the best way that
they can but thank goodness for the
citizens of California thank goodness
that they're pushing back and they're
giving President Trump the ground that
he needs to continue to go after these
these cities these states and say we're
not gonna do this anymore we're going to
sue you we're gonna take you to court
we're going to get these policies
declared illegal thank goodness now 37
jurisdictions guys are part of this so
37 jurisdictions all but one are
sanctuary jurisdictions La itself he saw
in that map had 16 Austin had 11 Santa
Clara California
which we don't delineate it this way but
that's we do all the California all in
one but Santa Clara California 22
Montgomery County Maryland which is just
minutes from where we're broadcasting
had five gang members released and an 84
from the year 2012 to 2018 in the shadow
of the nation's capital those are ms-13
Hector let's go to you so these
sanctuary policies just encourage more
illegal immigration and they also
encourage more crime within those cities
some of these illegal alien criminals
know that if they make it to California
or to some of these sanctuary cities
they know that there's there they're
free from law enforcement and they don't
have to work from law enforcement and
they will not be deported that's why
these sanctuary City parties are very
very dangerous well we see we see these
criminals being released and then we
also see in poor across the border and
we did definitely to secure the border
with that well in just a moment I'm
gonna share with our viewers the number
of people who across our border in March
this I almost fell out of my chair when
I read this but first I want to play
Jamil Shaw's father who was on Fox and
Friends this morning speaking about
Governor Jerry Brown given the fact that
he says we're not going to pay for any
National Guard troops do the work that
Donald Trump wants us to do let's watch
he just doesn't even care about the
victims like Rich's dead bodies or a
piece of trash in the cemetery and then
he's defending these legal alien
gangbangers and criminals and holding
them up like they're good people
knowingly from day one they broke into
the country and then they just finish
the communities no one does anything
Brandon very quick reaction first off
you have to feel for him you have to
feel for the family members of these
victims when you're talking about
Maryland I mean we had that that girl
that was raped in in school in in a
bathroom we have got to stop this we've
got to secure our border we've got get
behind the press that case was I think
it was reported one way at first then
they had to there was plenty of other
cases that are brutal and horrific right
in Northern Virginia by the way and in
Montgomery County I told you guys I
would
the number of border crossers and just
in March of this year there was a huge
spike thirty-seven thousand three
hundred and ninety three people crossed
into our country many of them will be
released back into society because of
our ridiculous credible fear rule that
has been abused we don't have time to
get into more of that we did that last
night
fantastic segment guy